hey everybody I'm Tiffany Smith for
Fandango and right now I am sitting with
Dwight Howard and we are talking about
your brand new documentary called in the
moment that is coming out on epic so why
do you think right now is the perfect
time for this documentary to come out
oh well it's something I've been working
on for a couple of years and I just
think that people you know they haven't
seen on the other side of me they
haven't had that opportunity to see it
from my eyes I think this is a perfect
time for and I've been in the lead for a
very long time and I haven't been able
to just express Who I am like I want to
and this is the time I wanted to be
Magic Johnson
I would say about 10 is when I told my
dad I wanted to go to the NBA
you said the way you want it baby to me
well you gotta sacrifice everything you
got you wanna make I said okay I think a
lot of people they always say I'm silly
they say I like to have fun which is
true you know but I do have a very
serious side to me just because I have
fun and smile and it doesn't mean I take
what I do with my life serious and I
want people to see that throughout this
documentary that you know a lot of
things that have happened to me have
made me a better person all right you
guys well thanks right now it doesn't
make sure you check out Dwight's
documentary on epics in mid-november
you